how are you feeling right now i don't
think my body understands what's going
on
intellectually i kind of do but my
body's going to take a bit of time but
i'm happy
i'm really happy there was kind of a
delayed response from you when they
called your name wasn't there
i guess so i don't know i was inside my
head
what is this what does this mean to win
and especially for a role
that was so powerful and for strong as
as far as representing a strong woman i
am so grateful to beth
um for many personal reasons but i also
think one of my favorite things about
her was because she was raised in this
interesting way she
never really saw her gender as something
that told her what she could or couldn't
want
and i really enjoyed playing that
especially in the context of the 60s
so i think more than playing a strong
woman i feel very honored to have played
such an interesting complex person
and that yeah no season two but
now maybe there's hope that there's so
much attention
and so and you win a golden globe can
you go back and conjure something up
maybe but you know not to disappoint
anybody but we just never thought about
it it was always
a sapling to tree transition you see her
grow you leave her in a good place so we
were genuinely
surprised when people were like where's
season two um
that being said i adore the entire team
that made it and i would jump at the
chance to work with him again
go back to 2014. you do a little movie
vampire academy they cut
your scenes and now here you are with a
golden globe
what would you go back and tell that
girl whose scenes got cut from that
movie
you're gonna love it even more than you
do now
so keep going you're just gonna keep
pulling more and more and more in love
with it and
it's gonna be wonderful and does it mean
more that you had to
you earned it you you worked your way up
through the business
it does in the sense of i feel so lucky
that every film that i do i learn so
much
you know it's it's an impression every
time you step on
a set with a new director and new actors
and you're just you're constantly
learning
so i think i feel very um i feel very
privileged and lucky to be able to learn
and grow with
people at the caliber that i get to work
with great transformation tonight do you
miss the red hair
yes i do but i have a feeling i'm not
gonna miss it for much longer so that's
okay
really you're you like enough already i
have so much fun
um being a chameleon so i'm sure that
when i miss it enough it'll
it'll come back the fan reaction and
celebrity at reaction people going crazy
over you
over your win what does that mean to you
oh i didn't know
oh yeah i've come straight into this
room
um but that's oh goodness i mean that's
that's so kind um
it's obviously wonderful to be
acknowledged by your peers
um but i'm just so grateful that people
connected with the story and they
connected with beth as much as they did
because she means so much to me that
whenever you do a project it kind of
feels like you're throwing your baby out
a window
and when you catch it that's just the
best feeling in the world
tell me about your dress tonight and did
you what was like the whole glam
process even though you never got to go
out and really
enjoy the glam oh we've had so much fun
we've treated this
entire experience as prom because i
never went to prom
so um we've had we've had a really good
time and the benefit
of not being in the room is that i got
to change outfits so i get two outfits
tonight which feels pretty cool
oh so you had two outfits there you were
set
[Music]
how are you going to celebrate tonight i
think i'm going to
breathe for a heartbeat and try and
understand what's going on
and then i'm going to put on some music
have a dance with my best friends
and probably end up with a grilled
cheese in bed watching a movie
that's kind of the dream right now has
anybody told you how you're going to get
your golden globe
no i have no idea and i'm assuming that
all those dings are people blowing you
up that a lot of folks are trying to
reach you right now
um i'm sure they are i have no i have no
idea what's going on i'm just
trying to trying to breathe and answer
questions in an intelligent manner that
doesn't make me look silly i think
that's kind of where i'm at right now
uh last thing this year has been a crazy
year and a tough year for so many people
but now will you look back and think
about how
this role came to you and was shown in
this year and helped so many people get
through the pandemic
as they sat in their living rooms and
watched the queen's gambit
yeah we just never would have assumed
that this would be
what was going on so it's it's special
congratulations enjoy this night and
thanks for everything you've done and
all your work is fantastic
and um pretty much dance your heart out
what are you gonna what's your what's
your song what's your dancing song by
the way
probably i mean i've heard it playing on
my friend's phone so probably do you
think i'm sexy
i think that's probably the first thing
that's going to be the first song and
i'm i'm
[Music]
there